announcement coming today we expect in
the 2024 presidential race Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida is expected to
officially launch his White House bid
tonight that much expected this was not
he's doing it during a live event on
Twitter with billionaire Elon Musk
DeSantis will join what is an
increasingly crowded field on the
Republican side of the aisle currently
dominated still according to polls by
former president Donald Trump Robert
Costa is in beautiful Key Biscayne near
Miami where DeSantis is expected to meet
with some long-time donors he's working
on that part of the campaign as well Bob
good morning
Good morning Tony it is beautiful here
this morning our latest polling shows
Governor DeSantis trailing former
president Donald Trump by more than 30
points the question now is can he close
that Gap but doing so will not be easy
get ready after months of anticipation
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis plans to
announce he's running for president on
Twitter tonight choosing to take
advantage of Elon Musk and his 140
million followers the first time that
something like this is happening on
social media and with real-time
questions and answers uh not scripted
DeSantis Ally say he'll play off his
combative politics alongside the tech
billionaire casting himself as a fellow
culture Warrior on a platform his
biggest rival embraced as president and
on Tuesday desantis's wife Casey tweeted
a video teasing her husband's Ron is it
worth the sacrifice
America has been worth it every single
time but DeSantis is now playing
catch-up former president Donald Trump
is firmly atop the polls despite several
legal challenges looming over his
candidacy Trump has charged ahead after
a CNN Town Hall earlier this month a
country has gone to hell and is forcing
DeSantis to fend off repeated attacks
Rhonda Sanctus today don't ever hear of
the Sanctus the sanctimonious but the
Florida governor is standing his ground
taking veiled swipes at Trump too I
think the party has developed a culture
of losing DeSantis popular with many
Republicans for his conservative
policies has come under criticism even
from some in his own party over a
six-week abortion ban he signed into law
and the NAACP has issued a travel
advisory for Florida warning recent
legislation is openly hostile toward
African Americans we're proud of what
we've accomplished in Florida but I can
tell you this I have only begun to fight
DeSantis team is confident that he can
build momentum in the coming weeks he
will be meeting with his donors in Miami
in the coming days before a formal
campaign launch sometime in the coming
weeks and then a trip to those early
voting States Tony
Bob before we let you go there are some
new developments in the federal probes
involving Donald Trump what have you
learned
there are some new developments in the
special counsel's investigation of trump
both on January 6 and on his handling of
classified records overnight Trump's
lawyers sent a letter to attorney
general Merrick Garland and in the
letter they said that they want to have
a meeting with the AG saying the former
president is being treated unfairly
without providing any specifics and they
asked for a meeting to discuss all of
these issues the Department of Justice
has declined to comment on the letter
this is at least the second time Trump's
legal team has directly engaged with the
justice department since the FBI
searched Mar-A-Lago and it comes as some
sources in Trump's Inner Circle say an
indictment on the federal level could be
imminent sometime this summer all of
this all of these legal challenges could
complicate Trump's campaign schedule in
the coming months Tony we shall see Bob
thank you very much